baby oh she started anyone going on
YouTube now recently if you guys have to
follow me on instagram you guys know I'm
back on my fitness crying again funny
fat fit second trial but it's been going
pretty well I've done about 10 pounds in
a month going to be working hard if you
guys want to see my products go ahead of
all me at David so fast I expected no
sir since I've been working on I've been
tending a certain commercial gym that
open 24 hours a day and I never really
understood why people hated commercial
gym so much until I started attending
them regularly for me it was like dude
you're working out it always sucks
anyways why the [ __ ] do you care what
the gym has or doesn't have well I know
why so it's been a while since I've done
what it is but you already know what it
is LGI baby let's get it let's go why
the [ __ ] is it that at every single
24-hour fitness there's [ __ ] like six
benches [ __ ] you need six benches for XY
and on top of there being six benches
there's like eight [ __ ] accessories
just for the chest or using their chest
that much to the guy that's only working
out his chest about 17 times a [ __ ]
day listen nobody [ __ ] cares for the
amount of time you walked out on your
chest [ __ ] I better speed you walk it
around with push-ups to tak how often do
you use your chest [ __ ] when you answer
a phone ah
remember to why the [ __ ] is there always
only one squat rack the [ __ ]
extremity you use on a daily basis is
the one that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
by order of importance if you're a guy
or a girl the muscle that's closer to
the dick or the vagina should be hook
support walking around looking like a
dumpling on toothpicks
there's so much real estate used on
machines that nobody uses come on 24
gives me something number three can a
[ __ ] please put his weights back
somebody I'll tell you this right now
you [ __ ] that don't know how to
put a [ __ ] weight back on the rack
you're the mother [ __ ] at least socks
everywhere in the house
time at the gym is spent just searching
for pins now if you workout at 24 and
you're offended by this I don't give up
but I enjoy the greetings I enjoy the
hell known but if you guys could maybe I
don't know walk around tell people to
clean up after their [ __ ] maybe respect
other people's space 24 look like after
everybody do a workout they just leave a
dynamite on their station all this talk
about there's no I swear to [ __ ]
Vishnu if you [ __ ] come up to
me I'm talking about you personal
trainers that are better than me come up
to me and ask me if I want to be trained
by you
oh [ __ ] is the before pic of B gonna ask
me if I want to be trained by him do you
want some personal training [ __ ] if we
had a bra contest [ __ ] you would
win I'm not saying if you're chunky
because I'm [ __ ] fat it but you don't
have the knowledge to maybe help me out
in my workout if you don't have to work
ethics yourself how can you help me you
know what's going to happen if you
[ __ ] personally train me want to
workout for two minutes I'm a whisper
french fries in your ear and [ __ ] you
and I are going to go on a date to
McDonald's and the last thing two people
can do stupid [ __ ] without [ __ ]
knowing for example in my workout
regimen I have one chest workout it's
just a bench so I love working out and
I'm about to hit the bench I start
benching and I noticed that the left
side is a little lighter I put it down I
look over there's a [ __ ] asian dude
with headphones on he apparently when I
was resting for like 20 seconds left the
[ __ ] ten pounds off my [ __ ]
barbell and decided to take it away
[ __ ] yeah that's like you eating a
sandwich and I walked up right in your
mid-bite and I slide out the tomato in
between it what you gonna do nah man is
cool Mallory like tomato just [ __ ]
put your finger right in it now I know a
lot of you are saying like how come you
just don't work out at barbell brigade
well here's the thing I do work out
there but when it comes to working out I
can't always just work out in one space
expecting me to always go there my
schedule is hectic it has to work out
whenever and however I can no excuses so
I will do 24-hour fitness that the best
thing about them is the fact that
they are open 24 hours a day and there's
a lot of locations so no matter where
I'm at I can probably get my workout in
to a certain extent so shout out to that
but other than that your [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] so if you're working out at the
24-foot your [ __ ] weights away I
don't give a [ __ ] if you think somebody
else isn't doing it so you're not going
to do it don't be a part of the [ __ ]
problem and on top of that please if
you're working out just work out don't
be sitting there [ __ ] Steve walking
next to your [ __ ] squat rack you [ __ ]
[ __ ] playing Pokemon go while people
are waiting a spot for your dumb ass god
[Music]